teaching center is brought to you by BMW
the ultimate driving machine
[Music]
hello and welcome to teaching center I'm
Boyd Maxwell with today's top stories
from the exciting world of teaching and
I'm Perry Schmidt well now we know the
long awaited announcement by star
English teacher Ruby roof has sent
teaching fans across the nation into a
frenzy I've enjoyed my time in Ohio very
much but I'm pleased to announce that
I'm taking my talents back to New York
City thank you very much
apparently PS 431 has made Ruby an offer
she couldn't refuse eighty million
guaranteed over six years there's
another 40 million in incentives based
on test scores this salary puts her
right up there with Rockridge
Elementary's Katie Hope and William woo
out of all right let's take a look at
yesterday's high school teacher Jeff
from Radio City Music Hall where central
Rapids high recipient of the worst test
scores last semester made the first pick
that was no surprise to anyone the first
pick central Rapids high takes calculus
teacher Mike Yoast from Tulsa Teachers
College
just like that you're a millionaire Mike
Yoast is an unbelievable story his
father living from paycheck to paycheck
as a humble pro football player kid was
a natural mathlete you know who's gonna
buy this mama house so you know this oh
there's no way around now you owe your
mom
today's highlight of the day is brought
to you by the 100% Black Angus beef
thickburger on a fresh-baked bun from
Carl's jr. and Hardee's now it's time
for the highlight of the day
so I hit the teacher Ashley Ferguson has
been running up them test scores over at
vinz clortho high okay Confederate
forces fired first can anyone tell me
where this battle took place now look at
this
she looks left then right looks past the
students with their arms up in the air
spots max near the back who sees that
even though his hand isn't up he's gay
max it was Fort Sumter that's right oh
come on so what she did there she's
bringing an introvert into the
discussion y'all
that's a Teacher of the Year play right
there that's right boy you know the
confidence game by Max by answering that
question correctly will enhance his
performance throughout the rest of the
year no doubt coming up after the break
Mayfield prep trades French teacher
Janeane Lowe to Skyline High for a head
librarian and too much ladies to be
named later hey we'll get the inside
scoop on the impending teacher strike
okay [ __ ] the season next up on
teaching Sam
strength courses through me
I am velocity I am I am a leader a
believer I am the force that guides
and the Gateway to what is possible the
path to the future
the future the all-new 2015 6 Series is
here meet the new teacher's pet
you